[Music]
damian clown has been a free agent for
nearly two months not much interest in
him in large part because there's no
ability to give him a proper physical to
determine whether or not he's healthy
also he reportedly wants a lot of money
he spoke with
mark berman of fox 26 in houston here's
what you davian clowney had to say i
just want to let people know i'm ready
i'll be ready to go whenever the time
comes whoever i sign with will get the
best version of me i'm working i'm
staying ahead of schedule and working
and i'm going to be ready to go when
training camp
starts he also hasn't ruled out a return
to the seattle seahawks who really
haven't shown the level of interest that
we thought they would i think they're
just waiting for clowney's financial
demands to drop clowney says he's got a
few offers but he's in no rush now he's
waiting for the right opportunity and
the right timing peter what do you know
what do you think what do you believe
about jadavian clowney's future in 2020
i've i've said all along that i think
the favorite in the clubhouse for
clowney is seattle
uh and i think that seattle's gonna end
up with either clowney or everson
griffin when the dust settles heading
into this season
um
but i do think
i i think the seahawks are being
absolutely right correct and fair
in holding whatever their contractual
line is on clowning and let's say i'll
pick a number out of the out of the sky
let's say it's 14 million a year i mean
let's look at davey and clowney's career
he's played six years in the nfl
set 32 and a half sacks
and if he played every game
like he played the monday night football
game against san francisco last year
he'd get a contract commensurate to what
reggie white earned in his career you
know dollars versus dollars
so but he doesn't do that and i'm not
blaming him he's had a lot of injuries i
get it
but the fact is
you are what you are
and jidavian clowney is a very good
football player who produces at the
highest level of football not every week
and look part of that has been injury i
get it
but i don't know why in the world that
there's this expectation that jadavian
clowney should make 18 million dollars a
year especially in this environment
where teams are not spending the way
they did in the past and i think part of
that is because of the current economics
and the situation that we have there are
not a lot of long-term big-money
contracts this off-season so i think
davey and clun if i were him i'd get as
much money as i could for two years
and prove that i deserve when the cap
really starts to go up prove that i
deserve really a significant bump but
based on what i've seen so far i would
hold the line the exact same way that
john schneider and the seahawks are
yeah well i mean peter you made a lot of
good points i mean you really did i was
going to make a lot of them you're right
i mean i'm connie when he's healthy and
ready to go i don't care what the stats
say he will ruin a game plan in four
seconds he is one of the best defensive
players in the league you know like you
said when we see him really healthy you
could argue he's the best defensive
player in the league he's one of those
guys mike that you and i talk about he's
got the f up the play stat he's been one
of the league leaders he can play in a
3-4 he can play enough for three you
know he is uh a guy like when you turn
on the film or watch a game on sunday
and he's in it you don't know if you
don't know anybody in the field you just
go man who is that guy he is big and
fast and he is aggressive and everywhere
i mean he's a game changer but he's
damaged goods to what peter said like he
he is and injuries are part of jedevian
county and that's unfortunate i don't
like that for him i really like this
player i mean he's one of my man crushes
right here but you know when you get
into micro fractures and lower br you
know liz franks and uh you know of
course what we saw this year with with
the core muscle surgery and all that
those are serious injuries for a guy
that plays defensive end and as physical
as he does so ultimately
i look at teams like i think what
genevieve has to do is what peter said
find a one a two-year deal it's kind of
i think how he's gonna have to live his
nfl career is on one and two-year deals
and just keep playing that way to
maximize it and i think there's some
teams out there that certainly could use
them and probably will overpay for him a
little bit on a year-to-year basis
yeah i think one year deal is the most
he can hope for now and you know any
time the argument comes up that all nfl
contracts should be guaranteed the easy
response is if that were the case they'd
all be one two at the most three-year
deals if they were fully guaranteed but
that may just be the way to davey and
clowny does exist in the nfl he never
gets that gigantic contract with a lot
of guaranteed money and you know it's
fully guaranteed for maybe two years and
then it's all fluff on the back end and
you know maybe it's better this way
maybe because you're not tied in they
can squat on you
because they have your rights beyond
that second year and maybe it's a great
deal for them so they keep you around at
a salary they like no just make it that
short-term deal go have an impact
and then go back to the trough the next
year and make what you can and and that
may be clowney that may be who he is and
what he is and i think every year there
will be someone who sees what he did the
prior year and says even if he's banged
up even if he's hurt even if he's only
gonna play 10 games i want that guy on
the field peter for 10 games
which is exactly how it should be mike
and
i i would love to have jadav and clowney
on my team absolutely love it but there
comes a point where you have to do the
responsible thing for your organization
you saw that list of injuries you saw
everything you know about his production
and look sac is an overrated statistic i
agree however
it is telling to some degree
and the fact is he's never had a
double-digit sac season in his career
he's averaged less than half a sack a
game and and again
don't take that for everything because
he can wreck games
right if he wrecked games every week
nobody would care about the the sax
stats he doesn't wreck games every week
he's either been too hurt or too
inconsistent to wreck games every week
and that's why you have to be
responsible when you go to negotiate a
contract with you davey and clowny right
like mike i thought like he would he
would maybe get a long-term contract a
less than the year-by-year salary cap
blow but mike you make a great point i
mean with an injury history like that
you don't want to okay yeah we could
have got out of this deal after two
years and move on but the guy that gets
injured as much as he does you might get
stuck with having to pay years three and
four if it was a serious injury or
something like that so that's the risky
part but he plays a premium position and
we know there's some teams like the
tennessee titans the eagles the jets
with some salary cap room and
the positional need to where i think
there's going to be a market for county
and he'll get some big money at least
for 2020.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports